[Musik]
kinder geschichten aus dem kanton luzern
doch geschichten für kinder sind es
nicht zu grausam sind sie auch schon in
ihnen viel von gott die rede ist
das einzig tröstliche an diesen
geschichten ist dass sie sich bereits
vor jahrzehnten zugetragen haben
in diesen beeindruckenden häusern in
diesen luzerner kinderheimen rathausen
etwa vor den toren der stadt luther
einst eines der größten kinderheime der
schweiz damals ein bedrohlicher ort wo
lachen verboten war
[Musik]
johannes lineker beardsley und dann
hätten wir da wunderbar in hollywood
ausgeschlossen
13 jahre eine ganze kindheit lang
verschwand etwas steiner hinter den
mauern von rathausen seiner frau wieder
das einstige gefängnis zeigen und bei
jedem schritt werden wieder erinnerungen
wach
aber einige meistens so im februar maria
lichtmess da hängt man am berg sein das
ist uns dabei dass sich die bürger es
verdient und dann ein bisschen leiser
mal auf und denken also war ich eine
stoppuhr bannerbug sie also wie der held
zur ehrenburg nordische qualitäten
thomas morus akademie und dann hängt sie
im haus müsse je nach dem wann ich wo
der figur von der kraft und intelligenz
das nicht fragt sie 12 50 und 150
franken zahlen
das eine hängt meistens hätte geist ja
auch und dann auspacken methoden und
handy und züge über und ich kann ja
nicht nur ihren 72 weil ich entweder zu
unter bulimie hat nur die monteure
geteilt sagt jörg hassink höre genau da
hakt er ab und vereinigt größte fall
ich hatte friedek fresse haut und das
geschlecht und deniz naki wurde und die
wir natürlich den bereich gesehen und
herstellt und ich weiß nur wurden
die oberin zeigt ja wie ist damit in das
serien intelligenter der 106 verbraucher
und der seitenlinie wenig da steckt die
skripte und klatschen windows xp sondern
mal ein bis zwei grünen mit dem bus
liebte mit der einfachen so sind sie
meine straße herrscht eine termin ja
sogar hat der oberministrant
dass bill black safe endlich schön dass
ich einmal aus um die gerne wieder jetzt
aufpassen oder blind boden tauschen oder
blind bode
das sind alles viele vereine xxi
wenn man aber alle mit den andern prolin
namen hat müssen
so zeigt etwa das ist doch dass ich sie
darauf wo man am karfreitag karsamstag
stadtkeller gott wie das hat sich der
inneren unerhört dass es schon deshalb
schluckte herr leuten osterglocken der
große orgel sowie und jubeln und
frohlocken von hinauf zu mir ist
versichert steiner das kulturgut teil wo
sie so emotionslos jetzt sehen dass ich
so viel leid und ich muss sagen ich muss
sagen ich habe man da sein können singen
statt
je nachdem wie er nach der abfahrt es
mithin der gardasee harper lee hofft
dass er nach sieben der befreiungsschlag
denn es sich so vorstellen noch ein
nachteil seiner dafür für rose und das
sind die schlimmsten sachen passiert
die schlimmsten sachen die frechsten
streiche der kleine eduard das darf man
sagen war ein aufmüpfiger war ab das hat
ihm viele schläge beschert aber wohl
auch das geschick an diesem ort zu
überleben und nochmals scheint das alte
große haus den rückkehrer mitsamt seiner
frau verschlingen zu wollen
die hängt deutlich vor der sächsischen
größe aber sie schreibe schön anderen
siegte mit 12 zoll problem die ganze
zeit bezahlbar zu wecken
das ist passiert in der kehle
nun ich noch vor dem ziel kam
dicke des steaks brutal ist rettet pro
tag manchmal foto vom spielplatz
was ist sehr hoch und ich sage in der
hochstraße und damit passt und david
treffen ja schon damit fleisch fleisch
und dann kommt er zu mir war mehrfach
den leib christi als mal und wasser
bezeichnen müsse aber ich will ihnen vor
dem hochaltar in gang
von der presse steht zwei bier gerieten
und ganz lud er liegt ein heiter und
denkt ist meer verschluckt wurde hatte
bremste das nimmt mir könnte verhallte
auf den halter wurde mache somit den
bürgern der hund einfach hinter ich also
mehr sein taxi in messing linear messing
schöne golden glänzen und hat mit
stofftieren meister und will ich am
morgen immer noch nicht verbessert
ich bin der herr doktor ich denke
regelschule hirn und 70 und da müssen
wir die 10 uhr besuchen verbracht und
sie hält den doktor verzählt ich so
starken abhängigkeit der opfer an der
schlage steiners ehefrau kennt all diese
geschichten erzählt immer wieder immer
wieder
1883 wurde aus dem einstigen frauen
kloster rathausen ein kinderheim eine
kantonale verpflegungs und
erziehungsanstalt für arme kinder
geführt bis 1976 von katholischen
personal einem priester als direktor und
ingenbohl schwestern als erzieherinnen
meist waren hier über 200 buben und
mädchen versorgt rathausen war eines der
größten kinderheimen der schweiz kein
massenbetrieb hinter klostermauern über
3.500 kinder haben hier in all den
jahren einen teil oder gar ihre ganze
kindheit verbracht hat steiner kam 1939
als fünfjähriger nach hausen ein
uneheliches waisenkind
der aufgeweckte bub wurde gedemütigt
verprügelt misshandelt und doch konnte
in rathausen nicht brechen
von ganz unten schaffte er den
gesellschaftlichen aufstieg und wurde
unternehmer den düsteren erinnerungen an
das kinderheim aber konnte er nie
entrinnen
im luzerner staatsarchiv liest etwas
steiner zum ersten mal was die
schwestern und andere amtspersonen
damals in rathausen über ihn notiert
haben sie die eltern gestorben
warum bekommt berufswunsch des steiner
eduard jordan 4 des kommissions- bruder
ausgesprochen übliche motivierung die
berufsreife ist noch nicht vorhanden wie
es zu den blues wunsch wurde schon
ziemlich eigenartig verwundert über
diese hinter sich also haben eigene
stasi bleibt wurde das betragen lässt
etwas zu wünschen über den punkt roh
verträglichkeit mit den kindern etwa
besitzt ein gutes stück diese
eigenschaften erschweren die erziehung
verhalten in der tiere stören
zusammenfassende schilderung ein echter
jugel auch die erinnerungen von eduard
steiner fanden eingang in dieser
aktuelle studie über die kinderheime des
kantons luzern
dieser film will auch zeigen wie viel es
brauchte ist dieser schmerzliche
übersicht zustande kam
josef grüter auch er schaute nochmals
zurück kurz vor seinem tod in einem n
drücker betagtenzentrum als uneheliches
kind war er nach rathausen gekommen die
mutter wollte nichts wissen von ihm zu
groß war die chance diese und das helmi
sowie der aus hohne hasse beruf die
wurde
wieso kommt dir nicht und sich um ihre
mutter sich bebaut wurde ich sehe sport
um in ihrer mutter ganga weh mir steht
gar nix sie hat mir kann aber sich nicht
also kein baby docs ist ja wahrlich war
nicht groß das einstige kinderheim wo
sein hass wuchs liegt fast in sichtweite
aber sehen sie doch noch immer hat dafür
dass tritte einfach die ideen da so
durch wie die diebe anderten und dies
hatte zwei stasi und liebe
der hamburger chaos patent die admira
war ja in der reiche stück brot sein
florett ist ja wir sind ihr motto ist
bietet sich hier die zahlen sind ist die
eine schale als hoch zur schau gestellt
ich möchte dass die täglich 150 jahren
kann ich das richtige büro erfüllt will
ich von ihnen eine frau warum wird baby
was ich wirklich liebe ich sie die
handtasche grüß gott das navi handys
gewählt werden die ungerechtigkeiten und
die hand auch fürs kleinste vergehen
das enttäuschende form eroscenter kopf
wurden vorschläge und zusammen mit
seiner frau lebte dort teile heute in
einem nutzer betagten heim als
fünfjähriger kam er nach rathausen klar
sind seine erinnerungen etwa daran wie
man gegen das bettnässen vorgegangen ist
und jetzt in der nacht immer am 12 hätte
dienst tuende ich möchte die hätte tim
einer größeren schlafe und der weg
gestellt am 12 ich aktiv wurde und hat
sammlerin trägt in einer kolonne auf das
bett dusche stahlhändler paravents
eskalierte und bett kontrolle und
werwolf das becken das wasserbett
vielfach daher führt wir sind von myra
kann die mai bis oktober
barfußlaufen zwecks schonung der schuh
die ortsteile kam zusammen mit seinem
bruder an diesen kalten ort
die alleinerziehende mutter eine witwe
verdiente zu wenig um die buben
durchzubringen
das grausame system und die trennung von
der mutter machten dem fünfjährigen sehr
zu schaffen und so suchte der kleine bub
den weg durch feld und wald zurück zu
seiner mutter
[Musik]
ich bin nur zweimal davon greife die 15
jährige ohne große orientierungshilfe
hat der weg von zürich trotz promi
mutter das zimmer und peter grant hat
auf der strecke quartett bisschen froh
war ruhig der nacht die werke sieg macht
mir die szene genau da fanden sich
wieder nach achtungserfolgen versetzte
anders werden ich bitte sie aber wir
hatten hier in der halfpipe
das luzerner dorf eschenbach unweit von
rathausen
hier kam hans widmer zur welt nachdem
sein vater gestorben war wurden er und
seine drei brüder 1935 von der
gemeindebehörde nach rathausen gebracht
hans widmer war fünf jahre alt als er
von seiner geliebten mutter weg kam und
für zehn lange jahre hinter mauern
verschwand wo er der lebhafte bub immer
wieder von direktor gottfried leise bach
verprügelt wurde
hans widmer hat diese strafaktionen des
priesters als pädophile übergriffe in
erinnerung dass sich ein
unwahrscheinliches hat echt gesehen
damit schlägt mit dreimal geschlagen
hätte tosic chlorid und das ruder von
der horster lotet das ticket
ich ziehe das schlägt will sammelt sie
sehen dem kann das angespannter hose und
das gericht sie dass er kontakte büro
hat oder als homosexueller pädophile
das kommt auch richtig dass sexuelle
befriedigung nicht der kleine hans
vermisste seine mutter sehr und so
schmerzt der die totale abwesenheit von
liebe den buben noch mehr als all die
schläge wenn es jetzt böse herrn die
heimat aus rom tausende weiber
streicheleinheiten und auch dem anspruch
dass wir endlich eine woche das
erstaunlich hinter der stunde zur neige
und rathausen war ein kinderheim für
mädchen und jährlich geborene weisen
solche aus verarmten verwahrlosten
familien
die mädchen waren von den buben getrennt
und die hausregeln waren unerbittlich
[Musik]
am morgen vom aufstehen weg bis nach dem
morgenessen nicht gespart werden
in schlafsälen und ab orten ist immer
strenges stillschweigen
der häufigste anlass für strafen waren
reden und lachen
eines der rat 1000 mädchen hieß anna
weber
stolz erhebt sich über malters der
höchste kirchturm des kantons luzern
noch weiter himmelwärts in diesem weiler
am berg oben kam 1939 anna weber zur
welt im alter von vier jahren wurde sie
vom vater missbraucht danach auch noch
von einem nachbarn
anna wurde was man ein schwieriges kind
nannte
so kam sie im alter von acht jahren nach
hause wo die schwestern versuchten sie
von den anderen kindern fernzuhalten
[Musik]
denn überhaupt mit einem typisch
spazieren
ich habe zwei musiker wenn 19
tatsächlich wurden mit den erlaubten
tätig die sich vermehre ich das immer
beruhigt sich
doch die co
mit keinem mittel hätte ich habe mich
kein mit der viel spazieren dass ich
lang lang sogar man sieht es auch
psychotherapeuten folgen
anna weber lebt heute in winterthur
sie ist fast erblindet und erhält
täglich besuch von der spitex sie wehrt
sich dagegen verbittert zu sein
trotz des grausamen starts in ihr lieben
das hier steht sie wo den langsam der
höchster co sind die jungs außerhalb
kostüm oder wo mir die gleiche sprache
versagt aber der besuch des knappen sieg
ist weiß gott was alles was sind die
ihre abwerfen was du alles ab und sie
sind zwar nichts merken
ja das ist doch schön dass sie das
dunkle er ist lokal von rathausen hat
anna ausgiebig kennen gelernt im
großraum erste stock das kruzifix
analyse
die grünen mit dem google und den
innenraum der tapete ich weiß gut
erwischt und chipkarten racing ducati
was er nicht mehr an der tu ich doch
nicht sie sagt sie sehen es so wie
hätten ruft die reagiert die pöttmeser
die hätten eine so reagiert dass man mir
es wird durch überhaupt schicksal
spazieren mit dem lindt durch nächste
mal im nächsten morgen verhandelt und
ich eine entschuldigung halt nichts was
man sie sehr groß gestellt daher
eigentlich sind vermutlich von ihrer
familie blieben anna weber nur fotos die
familie hatte mit anna gebrochen nachdem
der vater wegen kindsmissbrauchs ins
gefängnis musste anna war schuld daran
hieß es
im wohl hosen liegt das grab von anna
bühlmann
sie starb 1999 86 jährige einen teil
ihrer kindheit verbrachte sie zusammen
mit ihrer jüngeren schwester berta in
rathausen nachdem ihre familie verarmt
war
herthas starb in rathausen wo sie
begraben wurde ein unfall so lautete die
todesursache anna baumann hinterließ ein
tagebuch welches zehn jahre nach ihrem
tod auf dem estrich entdeckt wurde
darin steht die erschütternde wahrheit
woran ihre schwester berta wirklich
starb
das mädchen wurde von einer nonne
erschlagen weil es in der schule
unaufmerksam war schwester ursula nahm
ihren kopf und schlug ihn auf die bank
bis es meiner schwester schlecht wurde
sie gehen hinaus und musste erbrechen in
der lern stunde wurde sie ohnmächtig ich
sagte dann das sei weil sie von
schwester ursula geschlagen wurde
anna wurde deshalb bestraft auf befehl
musste ich die holzschuhe anziehen und
wurde in die dunkelkammer gesperrt die
nächte waren für mich ganz schrecklich
nachdem hanna der schwester oberin
versprochen hatte nichts zu erzählen
wurde sie nach zwei nächten wieder
rausgelassen unter qualvollen schmerzen
ist an meine schwester nach 14 tagen
gestorben im ganzen haus waren alles
sehr traurig es war der zweite september
der sarg und das grab war wunderbar mit
lilien und anderen blumen geschmückt
[Musik]
als todesursache wurde angegeben das
mädchen müsse sich irgendwo verletzt
haben
nur ein halbes jahr später wurde paul
will die von der gleichen schwester eine
große treppe hinuntergeworfen der war so
unglücklich gefallen dass er sofort tot
war
er wurde neben meiner schwester beerdigt
[Musik]
in der zeitung zentralschweiz am sonntag
die das tagebuch im mai 2010 publizierte
zeigten sich sowohl der regierungsrat
des kantons luzern als auch die
provinzoberin der in boulder schwestern
total schockiert 1000 liegt wie ein
böser schatten auch über dem ganzen
leben von walter bucher im luzerner
staatsarchiv sind die dokumente des
längst geschlossenen heims verwahrt
hier sucht der einstiger zögling nach
schriftlichen spuren aus seiner
unglücklichen kindheit da steht's
geschrieben 1942
damals kam fuhr als zweijähriger ins
heim
zusammen mit fünf geschwistern er blieb
unerträgliche 14 jahre lang
ja ich gerade da ist die frage fühlt
sich das kind wohl oder gehängt in
seiner umgebung und die große frage die
er fühlt sich wohl vor wo hat sie jetzt
das ja es ist natürlich gerufen der
vater war arbeitslos die familie verarmt
so gelangten die vier kinder an diesen
ort wo nonnen und priester zöglinge
misshandelten alois kampa war acht jahre
alt als man ihn nach hause brachte auch
er ein uneheliches kind fast täglich
liest er in der bibel
doch mit der kirche gebrochen groß ist
sein groll gegen den damaligen direktor
den priester antichrist hätte den
rothosen irgendwie projekt fürs land ja
ich kann mein gefährlich werden also ich
habe das gefühl aber ich gebe es zu ich
weiß nicht warum logik also ich denke es
wäre aber so kennt keine grenzen keine
wert sein
alois kampa und walter vorjahr waren zu
unterschiedlichen zeiten zöglinge in
rathausen bei einer besichtigung
versuchen sie ihre erinnerungen
aufeinander
zustimmen es gibt teile in diesem haus
die haben sich unverrückbar in der
erinnerung eingebrannt so das einstige
aris lokal das sogenannte rutschen kam
und was sollte das geht direkt und das
ist ja ganz sicher wenn gegangen ist
wenn wir für mutig
warum
in einer düsteren kammer entdecken die
männer die abgelegten requisiten eines
katholizismus der damals in den 40er und
50er jahren in der zentralschweiz sehr
mächtig war und im abstellraum kommt es
zu einer begegnung mit dem einstigen
peiniger direktor leise bach
[Musik]
der priesterliche direktor residierte
außerhalb der klostermauer in diesem
herrschaftlichen riegelbau das gebäude
ist ebenfalls umgebaut worden und wird
nun als verwaltungsgebäude genutzt
hierher zum direktor und seinem scharfen
hund wurden die kinder zu züchtigungen
beordert
und direkt in das ist poker und golfen
ist das hessische der reform wurde der
wolf als heimkind stand hans widmer
todesängste aus als er im
direktorenzimmer vom priester und dessen
hund attackiert worden war hätte bis sie
taugen nur für zocker etwa oder in der
nordsee oder ist da gucken und der
direkte merkel pocht und hat mit seinem
hund eine stoßen und und das buch war
nicht so viel kraft aber hat doch so
viel kraft entwickeln bisschen gesetzen
oder netto märkte so hanni messerkampf
vermutet und und das ist ja grausam ihre
identität war schnell ein punkt zum
frass führte herzlich aber befriedigend
network in dem moment in dem man mit dem
harz auch viele kommen ist sich
befriedigt oder pfannen erlebt als
person weise können hanami am gewinn der
makro ich will noch mal gelaufen ich
wollte grad
und wenn er wieder mal nach hinten
geschlagen hätten verschiedene
abteilungen immer alle 14 tage kontrolle
hat das kaiser
denn hätte sich mehr oder opern am hals
hätte können und hits in den usa zogen
extra in den import des vke wo das meer
um platz für exeters machen dass er
immer schön grad live wie sie fahnen
kast richtiggehend kasse
er hat mich mehrmals ins büro roboter
denn hätte mich genauso wie nie
auslernen große zehen pro fuß genau wie
auf der peene vielleicht
2 die dritte klasse und den hätte man
für shows gelohnt hat damit sie das
heißt auch grüße mit ihm passiert also
stoppelacker und dann hätte mich so vor
allem eine schwierigkeiten bin größer
und wollen mit den betrug sein vorsprung
im jahre 1949 beschwerte sich am
winterthurer form und über die
misshandlung seines mündels in rathausen
die luzerner regierung setzte daraufhin
eine expertenkommission ein die vor ort
ein trostloses straflager mit drei
dunkel zellen vorwand das urteil war
vernichtend zitat der direktor und
präfekt sind in erster linie strafe der
götter
man habe den eindruck dass die
primitiven strafmaßnahmen die
hauptsächlich ssten pädagogischen
handlungen darstellen würden
der priesterliche direktor wurde
entlassen
doch die peitinger 1000 dauerte an es
galt weiterhin leise bachs bekenntnis
zitat in der bestrafung der kinder
berufe ich mich auf göttliches recht
franz lustenberger er schminkte sich die
traurigkeit aus dem gesicht schwingfest
regel das ganze trotzdem
gesundheitliches problem wenn ich immer
mehr darum berufe wurde der elfjährige
franz lustenberger kurz vor seinem
verschwinden hinter den klostermauern
8000 das war jahrzehntelanges schweigen
bis zu meinem 65 geburtstag kommt die
weiter über die früheren verhältnis zu
hause noch über die vergangenheit die
man sie ins heim rathausen 19 einem 50
ministerium 53 reden
ich habe mich zu sehr gehemmt franz
lustenberger vater war ein trinker und
schlug seine frau zu hause fehlt das
geld die acht kinder mussten hungern so
stahl franz lebensmittel und kam
deswegen nach rathausen über franz
lustenberger schrieb eine klosterfrau in
den beobachtungsbogen er habe eine
übermäßige neigung zur geografie
jedenfalls hatte er eine übermäßige
neigung aus diesen mauern auszubrechen
über 50 mal versuchte er es in den zwei
jahren in denen er in rathausen
eingesperrt war
über fluchtversuche ist in keinem der
vielen rathausen jahresberichte etwas zu
lesen
für franz lustenberger endeten die
meisten ausbrüche im kohlenkeller des
klosters
mein glaube das recht am morgen aber
auch die innigkeit und videosignale ist
dass triton der hitze ins minus und rock
oder rap de cologne dass er den krank
macht dann eine sehr krank macht krank
macht das mit raten um den schlägen der
klosterfrauen zu entgehen will ich der
franz lustenberger in einen handel ein
via katholischer kaum sein könnte die
nonnen machten dem boden den vorschlag
in der maria zu weinen
damit wäre vielleicht alles besser franz
sagte ja und ich möchte die hoch
begeistert ich sehe die enthusiastischen
geglaubt hatte
und der held aus der wegwarte auch
später immer so und morgen mit 5,2 meter
gewann peter keller mit den banken
schneidet und das erklärt worden
die barmherzigen schwestern vom heiligen
kreuz an deren wirken erinnern sich die
einstigen zöglinge äußerst negativ sei
dass sie genau absolut die hexe sind
sich aber einig sie berichten für mich
sind die klosterbrauerei ward nur heinz
christ sehr genau wissen wenn zwei
hektar und herz und charakter was jetzt
passiert sind größe und güte gegen
unternommen
im talkessel von schweiz zwischen den
mieten und dem vierwaldstättersee liegt
der sitz der innen bola schwestern eine
trotzige anlage
das mutterhaus von heute noch 3900
nonnen gegen der ganzen welt gutes tun
in ihrem 150 jährigen bestehen zeigten
die ihnen bola schwestern
anerkanntermaßen ein starkes soziales
engagement in rathausen wird nun eine
dunkle seite dieser geschichte deutlich
die heutige ordensleitung weit entfernt
von damals ist zunächst irritiert ja
schockiert ob der vorwürfe sehr
betroffen gemacht
es zeigt dass es wichtig ist dass wir
damit ist eine aufgabe mit diesen
tätigkeiten kritisch umgeht und
hinterfragen und sich raum versuchen
erkenntnisse zukunft umsetzen
die mit sexyness noch einfacher die in
bolder schwestern haben eine eigene
kommission eingesetzt welche ihre heim
geschichte nun durchleuchten soll
die politische verantwortung für das
kinderheim rathausen trägt die regierung
des kantons luzern
sie hatte die katholische geistlichkeit
mit der führung des heims beauftragt sie
setzte eine aufsichtskommission 1
die welt schaute und sie verweigerte im
heim ausreichende mittel rathausen ist
geschichte
dunkle geschichte doch darüber fand im
kanton luzern bis ins jahr 2010 nie eine
politische debatte statt mich vor allem
offizielle vor allem wenn man selbst
erzählt als lügner
[Musik]
ich meine wald oder im büro
doch nun hatten erstmals einstiger
zögling über ihre kindheit im heim
gesprochen
öffentlich unter nennung ihres namens
und was sie erzählten war nicht mehr zu
überhören
auch die luzerner regierung hörte nun
hin
die erschütternden geschichten bewegten
sozialdirektor guido graf namens der
regierung entschuldigte er sich bei den
heimkindern zudem gab er eine studie in
auftrag
es ist die erste dieser art überhaupt in
der schweiz gemacht dass ich eigentlich
haben wir oft frage gestellt was ist
passiert und wir sollten immer über die
syntax konsequenz gezogen den
studienauftrag nicht ganz risikolos in
einem quiz was diego so wurde wohin sie
der hauptgebiete entscheiden sich nicht
darum was mir etwas abgeändert er nicht
sondern es ist der umgang mit übergröße
steht passiert und zwar aus dem grund
ich brauche sicherheit das was mich
heute mit also die haben sich dass das
gut ist dass das funktioniert oder ob
ich muss nämlich der ruhe und dass sich
die sich weit vergangenheit geschenk für
sie motivation sich mit seiner
regierungsmannschaft rang neun
die studie über die luzerner kinderheime
stützt sich auf 54 ausführliche
gespräche die historiker mit einstigen
heimkindern führten
das fazit ist eindeutig von sadistischen
erzieherin ist die rede von folter
ähnlichen praktiken von pädophilen
geistlichen
[Musik]
der historiker markus furrer professor
an der pädagogischen hochschule luzern
leitete die studie in welcher über die
hälfte aller interviewten von sexueller
gewalt berichteten und aufgehoben vor
der breite haarmühle jesko dass das brot
dass das handelshaus ed das motto form
phänomen stellt muss er verbreitet sich
die idee wie es betrachtet eigentlich
meistens personal insbesondere auf zwei
frühere direktor in ostrava und agronom
und auch hier ist zu andern heinig
besitzt ein kinderheim autos sind
darüber natürlich nur gerichtlich
belangt wurde
doch mal sagen da ich es überhaupt jetzt
sondern auch das ist alles unter dem
deckel drüber größte teil sollte nicht
nur rathausen auch andere luzerner heime
werden in der studie genauer betrachtet
so auch das kinderheim sonnenberg 70
buben waren hier bis 1944 untergebracht
damals publizierte der journalist peters
orava eine artikel serie illustriert mit
diesen fotos
er geißelte die dortigen missstände
übermäßige strafen essensentzug schläge
noch im gleichen jahr wurde das heim
geschlossen
der heimleiter wegen misshandlung eines
kindes verurteilt
das kreieren sein museum well park
widmete dem heim eine ausstellung und
lud zu einem rundgang mit einem
einstigen zögling das interesse an den
ausführungen von armin meier
nachhaltigen druck dass das kann man
sehr sehr schlecht behandelt
wirklichkeit nicht nur lobesworte man
sagen das ist gut gemacht das wollen wir
gar nicht richtig sind einfach die
ausgestoßenen der gesellschaft wo man
irgendwo hab mir sorge und man hat sehr
versorgt kinder geschichten aus luzerner
heimen einige davon sind nun publik
geworden jahrzehnte alte geschichten
doch sie haben die betroffenen ein leben
lang verfolgt bis heute das kraut das so
klingt die haben ja miterlebt dass
einmal und das ist eine riesenlücke ohne
ihre ganze aber dann spürte dass start
der innenstadt wie normales rennt vor
dem älteren sondern ich bin einige
stufen sie dieses projekt ikarus konzept
betont prim eine ca
ja so wie nichts
wirst du sie verbietet sich und einfach
was da abgegangen ist derzeit das gold
geholt die auch die luzerner
landeskirche hat ihre historische schuld
eingestanden und sich dafür entschuldigt
kirchenvertreter enthüllten in rathausen
ein mahnmal welches an das unrecht von
damals erinnern soll
jeder soll von diesem bäumchen äpfel
pflücken dürfen ohne deswegen in einer
dunklen zelle gesteckt zu werden
wer hungrig oder beeren herzens äpfel
stibitzt ist kann die
rathausen ist schon längst kein kinder
gefängnis mehr vor dem amtssitz des
einstigen peiniger dreht sich ein
karussell
es ist rathausen fest das fest der
stiftung für schwerbehinderte die heute
auf diesem historisch belasteten gelände
eine gute arbeit tut das erstmals eine
kantonsregierung den einstigen
heimkindern überhaupt zuhört verschafft
armin meier eine große befriedigung
nieheim studie die auch in seiner
unglückliche kindheit schaut ist ihm
viel wert ganz so wichtige entscheiden
sich richtig sie dass man jetzt wird es
ernst nimmt will die studien zeigt das
wird einfach ab wie das geschehe sondern
dass sehr viele gemeldet und audi
ziemlichen gleichen komplex und in der
gleichen ort die geschehnisse schildert
für mich bedeutet das für mini
reputation wunder endlich bewiesen dass
ich zwar im ring aber völlig ohne
jegliche schuld endlich nach dutzenden
von anläufen endlich offen ist und zwar
die wahrheit und davon lief
[Musik]
jahrzehnte hat es gedauert jahrzehnte
des verschweigens und verleugnens bis
der erste schweizer kanton bereit war in
die geschichte seiner kinderheime zu
leuchten
eigentlich müssten nun 25 weitere
kantone folgen
[Musik]